[Music]
Halloween is usually the perfect time to
show people how you'd look like dressed
as your favorite cartoon character but
some of these kids didn't need to wait
until Halloween to show us they are
totally twinning with cartoon characters
are you ready for the insane amount of
cuteness give this video a big thumbs up
if you still love watching cartoons
today we're discussing ten kids who twin
with cartoon characters Darla dimple
look-alike
do you remember honey booboo the
hyperactive beauty pageant girl from
Toddlers and Tiaras who became world
famous and got her own spin-off show
ever thought she looks similar to a
cartoon character we think she really
does look like Darla dimple from the
cats don't dance movie look at them
they're totally twinning without even
realizing it Darla's character is a
surprisingly similar upbeat personality
to Alana's although to our knowledge
Darla doesn't need any go-go juice to
stay hyper looking at this picture can
you spot the similarities the curly hair
the adorable layered tutu dress and of
course they're both wearing their
signature pink color Alana's fame
started with an episode of toddlers and
tiaras when she was just 6 years old her
over-the-top sassy personality captured
the world and her toddlers in tiaras
segment quickly went viral nicknamed
honey boo boo Alana quickly got her own
spin-off show which was on air for 4
seasons the reality TV show world is
nothing new for this little firecracker
but if she ever decided it was time to
test her acting her voiceover skills
Darla dimple might just be the perfect
character for this honey boo boo child
boo look-alike is boo your favorite
monsters ink character we can't blame
you she's absolutely adorable the black
haired big eyed cute little toddler
stole the hearts of many including this
little girls who might as well be her
human twin she looks like she's the
biggest monsters ink fan ever look at
her holding her Mike Wazowski and Sulley
did you know boos real name is actually
Mary she never tells her name out loud
but if you look closely you can see that
a name Mary is signed repeatedly on boos
drawings Mary Gibbs is also the name of
the actress who gave boo her cute voice
here's what Mary Gibbs looked like when
she was playing boo at just five years
old
and here's what she looks like now as a
college freshman she said she can't do a
cute voice of boo anymore but don't
worry this booth look-alike seems like
she's ready to continue the Monsters Inc
legacy we love that her pink hair bands
even have the exact same detail as boos
and she even has matching pigtails
what's your favorite boob Monsters Inc
moment ours is still the first time she
met Sully
and called him kitty Russell look-alike
movie up would definitely not be the
same without Russell the curious and
hyper wilderness explorer Russell
charmed everyone with his personality
and his unique look
he's adorably chubby dressed in his
wilderness explorer outfit which
includes a scout neckerchief and tons of
gadgets in his twice a size backpack his
look and personality are so unique
there's no way there would be a
real-life person out there who would
look just like Russell right wrong check
out this little guy standing in front of
the up poster if there's anyone who
would get a badge of the Russell
look-alike it would definitely be him
how cute is that did you know that
Russell was originally named a Lewis the
story team thought his name would cause
confusion with the Meet the Robinsons
character if you ever wondered how
Russell managed to sound so cute
throughout the movie you can thank his
voice actor who would sometimes run
around before saying a line Jordan a guy
might not look like Russell from up but
this kid sure fits the description of
everyone's favorite wilderness explorer
this has to be one of our favorite
cartoon character look-alikes ever now
all we've is Carl in the real-life
version of up we'll be complete linguine
look-alike if ratatouille is your
favorite Disney movie get ready for this
amazing accidental look-alike what do
you think could he pass as linguine
maybe it's the curly hair or his funny
pose on the photo but he is definitely
twinning with linguine the not so
talented ratatouille chef in the movie
linguine is very unsure in clumsy which
are the two traits no chef should ever
have but linguini was also very
kind-hearted and gentle which instantly
made us fall in love with him it seems
like this kid just needs a chef's outfit
and a hat and you'll be looking at a
human version of linguini we just hope
he's not as clumsy in the kitchen we
wonder if he has any pets like rats for
example or would that just take it too
far did you
linguini is actually a form of pasta and
its actual name means little tongues
speaking of ratatouille the very final
dish served to Anton ego in the movie
was actually created by a real-life chef
called Thomas Keller who owns a
world-famous restaurant in Napa Valley
that you're craving some ratatouille
right now do you think the boy in this
picture learned how to make the famous
dish eggs look alike
twinning with cartoon characters is not
an easy task usually they come with over
exaggerated features that go far beyond
human inspiration but for some reason
these kids keep on surprising us we're
halfway through the video but don't you
go anywhere because the next kid is too
cute for words and so is his cartoon
twin remember boxtrolls the 2014 movie
about the orphan called eggs who saves
the community of boxtrolls from
extermination it's a pretty unusual
movie but it has super adorable
characters and if you're into cute
looking monsters then this is definitely
a movie you should see who would have
thought that a kid could look exactly
like eggs well it turns out it's
possible check out this picture perhaps
it's his eyes his teeth or maybe his
hair but this little kid surely looks a
lot like boxtrolls his eggs eggs got his
name from the label on the box he wears
his clothes just like all the other
boxtrolls but unlike everyone else eggs
actually speaks English because of his
speech impediment compared to most
animations out there this is definitely
a unique movie with even better
characters who can resist the look of
eggs and his new human twin Dora the
Explorer look-alike get ready more
cuteness incoming we bet you know
someone who's a huge Dora the Explorer
fan Dora the Explorer first premiered on
Nickelodeon in August 2000 and no one
could imagine that this spanish-speaking
little girl would soon take over the
world
kids were completely head over heels in
love with her character and soon they
were able to buy Dora the Explorer toys
backpacks books games party accessories
and of course costumes but some kids are
lucky they don't need to dress up like
Dora because they already look like her
check out this cutie with her gorgeous
bob bangs and an adorable pink outfit
now there's someone who doesn't really
need to dress up like Dora she could
very well be her human look-alike Dora
the Explorer is known to be one of the
most popular educational programs for
kids the show has been such
hit it one quite a few awards including
a Daytime Emmy and NAACP Image Award for
outstanding children's program but apart
from that you can also find plenty of
award templates on the actual Dora
website where you can give yourself or
your friend a pat on the back
we definitely give our award to this
cute Dora look-alike Andy look-alike who
can forget about Andy Davis the owner of
all your favorite Toy Story characters
Andy is just a normal looking kid who
really loves his toys especially woody
well at least until he gets Buzz
Lightyear woody gets jealous of Buzz and
the two toys get lost when their family
has to move and the rest of the story is
history want to hear something that will
make you feel old Toy Story was 20 years
old in 2015 there's a constant debate
over who's the best Toy Story character
is it Hamm slinky dog Rex woody or Buzz
you decide and it looks like it's a hard
decision for Andy Davis's very own human
look-alike
check out this kid holding his very own
Woody and Buzz toys just like his
cartoon look-alike does in the movie his
hair and his facial features are
remarkably similar to Andy and it looks
like the two are totally twinning have
you ever noticed that actually all kids
from Toy Story have Andy's face no
really rewatch the birthday party scene
and you'll notice everyone pretty much
looks the same
looks like the toy stories have a few
more look-alikes not only the human
world but also in other cartoon
characters Phil's de Ville look-alike
get ready to go oh when we show you the
next picture and if you think it's
totally impossible for anyone to look
like Phil de Ville you might want to
rethink your statement
check out this kid rocking the haircut
adorable Phil de Ville is a 1 year old
toddler in the Rugrats movie and
television show and he's a sister named
lil they're always matching and we
wonder if this human look-alike also has
a twin sister who knows they might get
the part in the next Rugrats movie the
two might just be the greatest twins in
TV history as they somehow manage to
look cool in every single cartoon
episode remember when they starred in a
diaper commercial or the time they were
dressed in this and someone from tumblr
commented if that's Johnny Depp and
Helena Bonham Carter well we're pretty
sure this little gentleman looks mighty
fine in every outfit he's wearing too
and who knows he might be speaking
gibberish to you
you never know what this rug rat is
really up to kudos to you kid it's not
easy to look like Phil Deville who's
your favorite Rugrats character Phil de
Ville is definitely winning our hearts
Moana look-alike and one of the biggest
surprises when it comes to cartoon
look-alikes is without a doubt alii
Cavallo she is a 14 year old from Hawaii
whose voice is just as magical as her
looks doesn't she look like a real-life
princess in fact doesn't she look
exactly like Moana the resemblance is
striking but that's not even the most
fascinating part of this Hawaiian
princess's story the Disney characters
looks weren't even based on her Ali was
actually the very last girl that
auditioned for the part of Moana after
she was discovered by casting agents she
actually thought there was no way she
would even be considered for the role
alii is the youngest actress to ever
give a Disney Princess a voice and she
has the honor to play the first-ever
Polynesian princess how cool is that
it's just absolutely amazing how much
she looks like the actual princess in
every sense including her hair
mallanna's hair was designed so
precisely the team behind the movie had
to introduce brand new tools and
software to make her hair realistic but
it looks like Ally's hair is just as
fabulous we're pretty sure the two are
secretly twins and there's definitely no
other person out there who could play
Moana as amazingly as lde does Agnes
look-alike if you didn't think boo from
monsters Inc was cute wait until you see
our next cartoon twin give this video a
thumbs up if Despicable Me is your
favorite movie because we're just about
to show you the cutest kid who twinned
with Agnes check her out rocking the
exact hairstyle and clothes the youngest
of the despicable Me sisters trio is
arguably one of the most adorable
characters ever all she wants is a
fluffy unicorn and she holds her breath
until she gets her way Agnes is your
typical six-year-old and she really is
completely unicorn crazy
her unique haircut looks like it could
be very hard to style so we give huge
kudos to her human look-alike from the
fluffy red hairband to the two strands
on each side of her head this girl got
the Agnes hairstyle down to a tee her
yellow shirt and denim overalls the
little heart in the middle are perfect
and look at that sassy pose you
go girlfriend if you want to see what
Agnes would look like as an adult make
sure you check out the part two of our
ten kid cartoon characters reimagine as
adults
it looks like she'd still be just as
unicorn crazy as she was when she was
six don't subscribe to our channel and
give this video a thumbs up if you love
cartoons let us know which cartoon look
like was your favorite in the comments
below for more videos check out ten kids
cartoon characters reimagined as people
we'll see you next time bye bye
[Music]